there are currently 4.7 million people  who have been waiting to start treatment  these figures are the latest  as of the end of february 2021 we  know that the nhs have been under an  extraordinary amount of pressure  this is for treatments involving cancer  care minor treatments and as you said  there it is a record high  more than 30 387 000  people waited more than a year that is  the highest that figure has been since  december 2007  for a bit of context this time last year  the number of people waiting more than a  year to start treatment  was 1 600. but the fact that we've got  4.7  million people in england waiting to  start some form of treatment  is quite extraordinary we knew this  black backlog was going to be high  but that is a record figure